Ось моя дитинка. Якраз тоді ми чекали на зупинку,
як їхали з України.
Вона щаслива була зі мною.
Українська біженка у Німеччині - Ірина - вже кілька тижнів
не бачила свою 7-річну доньку Світлану вдома.
Він жде, він виглядає, постійно питає мене:
Де дівчинка наша? Кажи, де дівчинка наша?
Тепер з донькою вони зустрічаються лише під наглядом.
Тобто це тільки за столом, тільки ось так от -
я поряд і поряд сидять директор дитячого будинку,
і нянечка, і перекладач, і все це перекладають,
кожне слово. Ну так, як у тюрмі, "свіданка".
У квартирі лишилися хіба що малюнки дівчинки.
Вона мені малювала вже там, у дитячому будинку.
Я кажу: а хто це такі?
А вона каже: Мама - це ти, а це я, а це котик.
Малюнки переважно у чорних тонах.
Це виражає те, що у дитини глибока депресія.
Наразі Світлана живе у дитячому притулку.
Туди її направив Jugendamt -
німецька державна структура,
яка займається питаннями допомоги родинам.
Якщо виникають підозри, що в конкретній сім'ї щось
загрожує безпеці або здоров'ю дитини,
то Jugendamt може взяти дитину
під тимчасовий захист або ж і зовсім вилучити.
В Україні потрібно щоб поліція приїхала,
почула, що дитину ґвалтують і тільки після того цього
будуть її вилучати. Що ми бачимо в Європі?
Що там, якщо є навіть підозра,
вже приїжджають і відбирають.
Але яким чином Світлана опинилася у притулку?
До Jugendamt її мати, Ірина, звернулася самостійно.
Ми потрапили в готель (як біженці),
проживали там у готелі з дитинкою пів року.
Потім я ж з першого дня звернулася в Jugendamt,
щоб вони мені знайшли житло,
тому що готель для дитини категорично не підходить.
Також, за словами жінки, вона неодноразово
зверталася в організацію за різною допомогою -
щодо пошуку перекладача, різних курсів, садочку.
Знайшли нам дитячий садочок.
Дитинка пішла в дитячий садочок,
але буквально через місяць її вигнали.
Коли я запитала, що відбувається,
вони сказали, що дитина взагалі неслухняна,
що вона не виконує їхні прохання.
Коли я запитала в дитини,
чому так відбувається, вона сказала,
що її там ображають, б'ють
і що її там ніхто не розуміє.
Після виключення із садочка –
дівчинка пішла до школи,
де у неї теж були проблеми із поведінкою.
Світланку тричі тимчасово відстороняли від навчання -
як зазначено у документах - "за погану поведінку".
Потім школярку направили до третього навчального
закладу, вже для дітей з особливими потребами.
Ця школа була саме для такої дівчинки, як моя,
тобто для гіперактивних таких дітей.
Так, вони визначили діагноз їй - гіперактивність.
Під час літніх канікул Ірина знову попросила Jugendamt
про допомогу - відправити Світланку у дитячий табір.
За словами жінки, вона була упевнена,
що везе дитину саме у табір.
Утім виявилося, що вона привезла дитину у дитячий центр,
де про неї піклуватимуться працівники центру
і не повернуть дитину матері одразу.
Коли Ірина зрозуміла це, вона сказала працівникам
дитячого центру, що родина вертається в Україну.
Ви сказали, що ви забираєте доньку додому, в Україну?
Негайно, негайно. Так, я сказала, що на правах матері
я забираю дитину з вашого закладу негайно.
Про повернення родини в Україну Ірина обмовилася
і до цього, в спілкуванні із соціальною працівницею,
яку їй надали в організації.
Жінка каже, що мала на увазі не повернення назавжди,
а просто поїздку до родичів.
Це Jugendamt вже коли в мене буде суд,
вони сказали, що через тиждень у вас буде вже суд.
Я запитала, в зв'язку з чим вони сказали, в зв'язку з тим,
що ви збираєтесь їхати до України, а там небезпека,
там війна. В Києві, я живу в Києві, там нема бойових дій.
До суду на Ірину подав Jugendamt.
В документах зазначено, що "приводом для звернення
до суду стало бажання матері повернутися до України,
де йде війна, разом з дитиною".
Крім цього, Jugendamt просить "як мінімум, позбавити мати
права визначати місце проживання доньки"
та "призначити відповідальною" за всі питання,
які стосуються дитини "Міську службу з питань дітей
та молоді". Тобто частково позбавити
Ірину батьківських прав. Але сотні мам їздять
з-за кордону до України з дітьми і назад.
Хіба це заборонено? Роз’яснює експертка Дар’я Касьянова,
яка разом з командою займається захистом
прав дітей в Україні.
Якщо мама знаходиться в тимчасовому прихистку,
все одно вона живе в законодавчому полі тієї країни,
куди вона приїхала. Якщо ми кажемо про безпеку,
вона тут базова. Вони приїхали в країну,
намагалися отримати безпеку перш за все
і отримали на цій підставі тимчасовий прихисток.
І коли вони хочуть повертатися назад в Україну
і забирати дитину туди, де і є небезпека,
то на жаль, це буде трактуватися як повернення в
небезпеку, що порушує права дитини
і найкращі інтереси дитини на безпеку,
на життя, на здоров'я.
На наш запит в Jugendamt відповіли, що не мають права
надавати будь-яку інформацію через захист
особистих даних. Втім, історія Ірини - одна із сотень.
Причин, через які інституція з захисту дітей
може зацікавитися родиною – багато.
Я наголошую на тому, що вони це роблять превентивно.
От якщо є хоча б одна підозра.
В нашій реальності дитина може бути в небезпеці
в сім'ї наркозалежних багато років.
Сусіди будуть це бачити і не будуть викликати поліцію,
тому що… ну а що тут, ну от так відбувається, на жаль.
Насильство над дітьми в нашій країні ми дуже толеруємо,
дитину б'ють чи кричать, чи якось психологічно її
намагаються покарати. Ми на це не звертаємо уваги,
тому що це така практика. Тому що ми вважаємо,
що це така наша культура. Насправді це порушення прав дитини.
Приводом для звернення до Служби з питань дітей можуть
бути гучний крик із сусідської квартири, дитячий плач,
наявність на обличчі дитини подряпин чи синців,
або не відвідування школи. І повернення з родиною
в Україну - це не єдина причина з якої Іриною
та її донькою зацікавився Jugendamt.
У матеріалах справи бачимо - соціальна працівниця
повідомила, що Ірина показує "ознаки психологічного
відхилення". У документах Jugendamt, зокрема,
йдеться про те, що "надмірно обтяжена ситуацією мати
перебуває у стресі", а "дитина, демонструє дивну
поведінку і потребує особливого догляду".
Ці мами дуже травмовані. Вони постраждали від війни,
вони приїхали в іншу країну, де інша культура,
інший менталітет, інше сприйняття того,
що відбувається в Україні. І дуже часто ці мами
самостійно приїхали. Тобто мама, наприклад,
і одна дитина, чи дві, чи три дитини, і їй складно.
У ситуації з Іриною дитину вилучили,
оскільки побачили пряму загрозу її життю.
І тимчасово помістили дівчинку у дитячий центр.
Що робити батькам у таких ситуаціях?
Ну якщо вже вилучили дитину?
То перш за все я думаю, що треба проінформувати
Національну соціальну сервісну службу України.
Обов'язково треба проінформувати офіс… В нас є дві
інституції - це офіс омбудсмена і офіс радниці
уповноваженої з захисту прав дитини.
А там же я знаю, що вони включають механізми
співпраці з міністерствами в Німеччині і з консульствами,
з представниками в Німеччини для того,
щоби вирішити цю ситуацію якнайшвидше.
Дізнатися більше і допомогти батькам
повернути своїх дітей.
Перше судове засідання - відбулося.
Ірина виходить з посмішкою.
Раз на тиждень мені дозволено зустрічатися з донькою.
Слава Богу, хоча б за це дякую.
Доньку Ірині таки повернули. З документів,
які показала Ірина, випливає, що між нею і Jugendamt
було досягнуто угоду. Згідно з нею,
вона зобов'язується піклуватися про добробут дитини,
не наражати її на жодну загрозу, приймати допомогу
Jugendamt і надати документ про своє фізичне і психічне
здоров'я. Якщо Ірина порушить умови угоди,
дитину в неї можуть знову забрати.
Перед виходом матеріалу ми отримали повідомлення від Ірини.
Вона з донькою повернулася в Україну.
Як написала Ірина - назавжди.